grazie
tra gli amici per un attimo bella riga
dio mio beh frate ascoltati mi metti
nello zaino
mi metto davanti a top non mi toccare il
pene per fare e lui è chillari cosa fa
[Musica]
liberati dei colli asterisco asterisco
asterisco
nin che non ti piacciono
[Musica]
partirà
ma andiamo a registrare qui
[Musica]
ecco questo è il mio portinaio che mi
apre la porta
[Musica]
si inizia dicendo noi no noi
ma esiste un altro modo per evocare un
demone se vuoi provare devi metterti
davanti allo specchio a mezzanotte e
dire tre volte bloody mary ad alta voce
vedrai cosa fare
[Musica]
lodi mary mary testa di cazzo sto
dormendo si torni qui [ __ ] basta 10
chilometri una dall'altra
[Musica]
grandissimo pazzo e la madonna cos'è sto
ragazzo un orologio swag
[Musica]
es
frena cazzo intascherà questo cuscino
[Musica]
gaia è un grande abbiate pazienza però
me ne vado perché anti cambia mezz'aria
facendo un giro di 360 gradi
[Musica]
e morto fai un video con sheila bair
dovrei parlare in inglese per farlo io
oggi come posso che la icann due test ok
ok come siamo arrivati a 1.800.000 ga
miglior 900 mila bambine nel mondo
calzamiglia 1.800 euro del nesquik
[Musica]
aspetta un attimo che ci mia madre che
ovviamente li chiama se non è contenta
nota java ma ascolta riina aspetta
aspetta sto per eseguire un trapianto
molto pesante quindi un attimino per non
lo salva un vagabondo ormai per mia
madre è normale tra l'altro ragazzi
nelle prese della corrente in america
sono sono troppo tristi
[Musica]
ora mai canestro senza guardare chi si
sky forum
[Musica]
mi ha regalato una una borsa io sono un
maschio va ma questa cosa è molto trendy
[Musica]
guardo il cielo non vedo altro colore
solo grigio piombo
dai dai dai
guardo il cielo non vedo altro colore
solo che io di te marrakech salsiccia in
line
io non so che cosa cazzo sono questi ma
sono veramente figli
[Musica]
se prendi questo pari per caso ai peli
sotto l'ascella e no però le ascelle
sotto i piedi
quante magliette riesce ad indossare a
via 123456 e con questi ragazzi mi sento
tipo un bong 7 8 9 10 sto morendo di
caldo in una maniera che non potete
capire 11 12 13 14
non ce la faccio più rega 15 16 o mio
fermi un attimo da ricami mi sento così
la cosa impressionante per mille 17 18
19 20
basta ragazzi basta non ce la posso più
fare sto morendo fantastico perché
perché mina era un faranno labati può e
adesso ho mangiato anch'io a mcdonald si
vede mai a siamo a luglio ma diversa
oggi cazzo
vado a mettere il costume qui ragazzi
che cazzo faccia oggi si riparte
condiviso quindi spero che mi sia
piaciuto è come al solito ragazzi
servito vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come noi video trovata
notizia non sapersi diavolo ci diamo un
prossimo video della ragazza